it can either feel elegant or like a
porn star I'm not gonna lie to you I'm
kind of scared of this this really what
my fingernail would feel like if it was
isolated it got my nails lined up I have
to hold it for a bit or just know okay I
glued myself to myself it's one of these
moments where you realize that like oh I
use my thumbs a lot oh that one kind of
hurt so that kind of digs into my skin
but it looks better PD is paint oh it's
hard to do stuff already it's kind of
like a talent I feel a lot less in
control of my hands and my fingers like
this is what Gollum would look like
building a model airplane got it ooh I
could seduce a younger man right now
kind of feel like a little bit like
Edward Scissorhands a little bit you
know like maybe I could go around to
bushes and just like this is one of
those things where if if life is gonna
be much more difficult with these and
without these then I really don't get
these okay this is hard I'm trying to
get it out of my pocket putting these on
I don't want to break them
damn it would be hard to text your
grandson you should press my buttons
like this and now I have to go like that
I like using like my swipe feature on
this it's way too hard to use to use
swipe and it's even harder to like
delete to delete stuff because my
initial entity to type it with my nail
all right I'm getting better at it
better at it but I definitely have to
ingest how I do everything I'll text my
mom I'm gonna trying I'm gonna take a
little selfie here
these nails say I really like to
Instagram to a selfie okay this is this
is just difficult
hashtag nope that's a percentage Siri
and Google Voice that's probably for
people that have this
it definitely makes you feel a different
way which is a combination of like
dainty and in control I feel like it I'd
have to go through something like 80s
montage training to figure out how to
use these I like the freedom that my
fingertips give me why I never go up to
a woman be like I like your nails I
can't be a big opponent of them I kind
of dig them I can I can see what it's
all about my initial instinct was to say
like why would you want to grow your
nails out let that makes your life
harder yada yada yada but at the same
time like I don't want to invalidate
what you want
wearing new things like obviously makes
you feel a different way and that's like
one of the most interesting things I
feel like I learned from like these try
a fashion for the first time is like
there's a specific way that something
like this makes you feel and that's kind
of the fun behind it and that's kind of
the fun behind fashion in general